carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
un gusto saludarles desde nuestros
estudios en parís para este nuevo número
de carrusel de las artes que nos lleva
en esta ocasión a explorar el cine
latinoamericano y francés y lo último de
la música electrónica en francia
vuelve sin el latino de tu luz del
festival dedicado al cine
latinoamericano tendrá una versión
virtual por causa de pandemia poniendo a
disposición la mayor plataforma online
en europa dedicada a las películas
latinoamericanas una comedia a viole con
gana el premio césar a la mejor película
francesa del año en una velada en la que
los artistas clamaron por la reapertura
de las salas de cine
y en nuestra crónica musical
conversaremos con el dj francés jeremy
suya alias mon quien acaba de sacar
flashback fm un álbum electro con
sonoridades de los años 80
[Música]
comenzamos nuestro recorrido cultural en
la ciudad de toulouse en el marco de
cine latino festival dedicado
exclusivamente a mostrar el cine
latinoamericano en francia y como muchos
eventos culturales en tiempos de
pandemia si el latino se ha dedicado a
lo virtual este año tras haber tenido
que anular su edición en 2020 pero este
año habrá dos momentos uno virtual en
marzo y una versión presencial prevista
para el mes de junio y para hablar de lo
que trae cine latino este año conectamos
ya mismo con la coordinadora de cine
latino
mallorquín eba gracias por estar con
nosotros cuéntenos cómo se va a llevar a
cabo esta doble edición del festival
cine latino
muchas gracias a maría carolina por la
invitación y darnos la oportunidad de
presentar esta esta versión histórica
vamos a decir de destinar el chino ya
que vamos a
a tener una experiencia totalmente
inédita de organizar y de tener un
festival online ya que el festival 33
será en dos sesiones una sesión online
del 19 al 28 de marzo y una sección en
presencial del 9 al 13 de junio
hemos decidido detener esta doble
festival porque no queremos cancelar el
festival otra vez como como fue hemos
tenido que hacerlo el año pasado
entonces para asegurarnos de detener a
festival hemos organizado esta
plataforma online así tenemos la certeza
de cumplir con la misión del festival
que es apoyar el cine latinoamericano
porque una plataforma no es el cine una
plataforma no es un festival hemos
estaba organizado un segundo tiempo en
físico para abrir este espacio de
encuentro que vaya en esta edición
virtual de cine latino este año van a
poner todas las películas en una gran
plataforma quiere decir que va a ser una
de las más grandes quizás en lo que
respecta al cine latinoamericano
bueno en europa no creo que hubo una
plataforma que ofrece tantas películas
latinoamericanas de una sola vez
porque son más de 100 películas
accesible toda francia es decir
películas como largometraje escalo
cortometrajes ficción documental
animación en la plataforma serán
accesibles las películas de competencia
competencia de largometraje de ficción y
documentales largos y cortos de ficción
y documentales los largometrajes de
ficción y documentales son películas
inéditas en francia es decir que hasta
que sean propuestas en la plataforma no
fueron vistas en ningún lugar todas las
películas por supuesto están
subtituladas aire francés y somos muy
felices también poder presentar la
competencia del año pasado una
competencia de largometrajes de ficción
y vamos a tener la posibilidad de
presentar nueve de las doce películas 12
películas de ficción en la competencia
también habrá cortos y documentales
lleva una sección especial en homenaje a
la gran actor chileno alfredo castro con
una selección de sus películas
sí exactamente alfredo castro nos ha
dado la confirmación de su presencia de
junio sí sí por supuesto las condiciones
le permiten y bueno
alfredo castro es uno de los grandes
actores latinoamericanos del cine
contemporáneo su carrera es totalmente
impresionante en francia ha sido
revelado internacionalmente por tony
manero en 2008 una película que hemos
apoyado con cine confeccionar el
dispositivo dedicado a apoyar los
cineastas latinoamericanos al momento de
la postproducción que organizamos desde
20 años y para nosotros
bueno descubrir el cine de pablo la
reina y descubrir alfredo castro fue así
un verdadero chat como es un actor que
ahora tiene una presencia muy fuerte que
es un actor que tiene una técnica
estupenda un actor generó su sutil
valiente y comprometido en sus papeles
hemos querido dar
rendir como un homenaje o dar un espacio
a el feto castro que seguimos finalmente
desde mucho tiempo gracias se va amor
quien coordinadora del festival cine
latino de toulouse por haber estado con
nosotros y seguimos hablando de cine
porque la academia francesa entregó sus
premios césar la ceremonia se hizo en la
mítica sala olympia sin público por
causa de kobe y en medio de una
situación delicada a las salas de cine
siguen cerradas y las producciones
paralizadas desde hace varios meses aquí
en francia pero los artistas
aprovecharon la ocasión para hacer un
clamor en favor de la reanudación de la
actividad cultural nos lo cuenta melissa
barra
[Música]
la velada de los premios césar tuvo su
lote de sorpresas empezando por sus
distinciones la cinta a dio le cum de
albert dupontel se llevó siete
estatuillas entre ellas el césar a la
mejor película
en raras ocasiones películas de comedia
se han llevado tal recompensa pero este
año de pandemia ha tenido un impacto
importante en la cantidad de películas
que podían pretender a los galardones
[Música]
y la película de animación josep sobre
el dibujante español y militante
antifranquista josep bartolí recibió el
césar de la mejor película de animación
su director o gael ya había sido
distinguido en festivales y premios
internacionales entre ellos el linier de
la prensa extranjera en francia
la cinta solo estuvo cuatro semanas en
las salas de cine y sin embargo tuvo un
éxito mayor de lo que esperábamos fue
una hermosa sorpresa tener notas
positivas del público y de la crítica
la noche de los césar tuvo además un
sabor reivindicativo en medio del largo
cierre de las salas de cine en francia
el gobierno francés fue el blanco del
clamor político la actriz cojín masiero
incluso protestó desnudándose sobre el
escenario y escribió en su piel sin
cultura no hay futuro
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ahora ya de hablarles de música para
ello ya está con nosotros natal y
olivares natalia hoy dedicamos nuestro
espacio a un joven artista llamado mom
que se perfila como el heredero de la
french touch y nada más eso es maría
carolina mont que significa niño en
español está en la actualidad francesa
en la actualidad musical francesa por
eso tuvimos que ir a su encuentro ahí
mismo donde compuso su nuevo disco
flashback fm
[Música]
estamos en el distrito 9 de parís aquí
en el barrio del mítico cabaret le fue
una idea real y aquí mismo en este mismo
barrio está el sello musical a luz
flórez donde produjo su último álbum el
artista mundo el disco se llama
flashback
efe jms él se llama mode y lo vamos a
descubrir
[Música]
mi año
cuando tengo un instrumento en las manos
vuelvo a hacer como un niño no significa
niño y nadie me puede parar
no lo puedo largar y soy capaz de
comportarme como un niño para no soltar
mi juguete esa es la idea de sin hogar
verde
[Música]
back fm compuso lo compuso en
colaboración exclusiva con ricky ducati
que se encuentra en los ángeles es una
colaboración a distancia pero con un
mismo objetivo
[Música]
a estas plazas y asma que fm es una
vuelta al futuro inspiraciones del
pasado con sonoridades de hoy es revivir
lo mejor de los años 80 antes de la
disco y una mezcla con música
electrónica de hoy con el estilo de la
french touch
este álbum cuenta también la amistad con
ricky ducati que nació de una conexión
musical inmediata porque nos gusta lo
mismo y es raro encontrar a alguien con
quien compartir se acerca de músicas muy
específicas de una época que nosotros no
hemos conocido nosotros somos de los 90
esto nos dio ganas de ir más lejos y de
crear un álbum afectivo no tiene aún
quizá montes batallado continuar
[Música]
elemento importante maria carabina para
conocer a mom y es que se nutre de sus
múltiples viajes y nos contó su paso
rápido por méxico
trabajó en este disco desde hace dos
años y en dos años he dado una vuelta al
mundo incluso pasando por méxico fue
realmente loco estar ahí porque estaba
programado justo después de metro no me
quién son super conocidos allá y en el
escenario he sentido que a los mexicanos
les gusta el aire el rock les gustan las
personalidades auténticas que dan todo
arriba del escenario eso es lo que yo
sentía aquí es todo lo contrario todo
más superficial en parís
me acordé de todo lo vivido en méxico en
los ángeles y también en canadá cuando
escribir y es así como lo hice
desgraciadamente no volvía a viajar
efe
e
volver a viajar es un sueño para el que
quisiera realizar y sobre todo
encontrarse con su público
latinoamericano en una cultura fuerte en
américa latina y es lo que yo blasco
cuando voy a un lugar
estoy seguro que si voy la conexión va a
funcionar todo va a explotar y que la
voy a pasar increíble remy cráter abajo
muchas gracias mon por haber estado con
las gracias entonces próxima cita hasta
pronto en américa de entidad
[Música]
ahora
la fm de ese artista que nos viene de
niza con un éxito planetaria lo
recordamos en el 2016 con su éxito lo
halagó ja exactamente a loja flashback
fm yo creo que va por el mismo camino
gracias natal olivares y bueno propongo
que nos movamos un poco con la música de
mom y ricky ducati nos despedimos con el
tema ay nou gracias por haber estado en
nuestra compañía les decimos hasta la
próxima cuídense mucho agua
[Música]